lincoln said
that nearly all men can stand adversity
but if you want to test a man's
character give him power
do you think power and money can corrupt
most people and if so do you worry of
this corrupting force on your own mind
you're one of the leading minds in the
cryptocurrency space
you're the leader of the cardano project
you're the king of the rats
of the rats uh does this corrupt your
mind
both the power and the money of it yeah
i mean you see this most pervasively
with
people who inherit a large amount of
money or our title
uh like you know dynasties like the
melons or the rockefellers or other
people is the worst thing you can do to
somebody is just hand them an enormous
amount of power that they're not
prepared for
uh and the challenge with this space is
like everybody's young
and we're all billionaires now and we
have these call followings and do all
these things right
nobody really says no to you like for
example like i have this
ranch up in wyoming and it has 400 bison
on it
so now i'm a bison rancher like if
if somebody if somebody was like
monitoring auditing that'd be like
charles do you have any experience
raising taking care of bison i'd be like
no
so you think it's really a good idea to
have this ranch with 400 bison running
around what the hell are you going to do
with buys i just have to figure out
what i'm going to do with these bison so
and i you know we'll make a video game
we'll do crypto bison
um but uh and you're going to get one
i'm not pulling out
thank you i i would love to i'm not
pulling at that string just yet so
i'm wondering how are you going to
connect this back to power right
and so but my point is that when you are
unrestrained like literally
no one can say no or you you have the
ability to distort reality around
yourself and you're not constrained by
social uh customs it creates
a a situation where you start losing
perspective
you're not grounded anymore i think so
it's less of a question of will you
become evil or not
it's more of a question of will you lose
so much touch with humanity
that you just can't relate or understand
people and then you inadvertently by
your actions start harming people
either through the policies that you
pursue or you know
the things that you start building and
so forth so
i think the best inoculation against
that is to surround yourself with
activities that are utterly divorced
from your reputation and status
the best thing are animals and gardening
because you know a donkey doesn't care
if you're a billionaire or broke he'll
on you exactly the same way
yeah and so so there's a humility behind
these types of activities and these
things
and there's a a honest work component
like when you grow hay or whatever
you have to plant you have to actually
water you have to irrigate you have to
actually be there and if
you can't use some excuse while i was
meeting the president of el salvador
i was doing this like the hate doesn't
give a it's hey
right so it grounds to connect to you
the other thing is you have to get used
to giving away
all the best things in my life have come
as a consequence
of first giving like i got started in
the cryptocurrency space by giving away
a free class
bitcoin or how i learned to stop
worrying or love crypto you did a free
podcast
right in life if you give and you
develop that mindset
of i'm not attached to the things i have
and if push comes to shove it goes away
usually you get more back like i keep
away all my ether i never received any
of 293 000 ether at the all-time high
over 1.2 billion dollars
i gave it to my secretary i had no idea
if it was gonna be worth anything or not
but he kind of got shafted and i was
like well
they don't like me so they don't like
you by the transitive property of
relationships so you're screwed and it's
like well i'm gonna go back and my wife
is probably gonna divorce me and all
this stuff and
what do i do i said i'll give you my
ether i don't know if it's gonna be
worth anything
so you know he's still pretty good uh so
you know
but then again regardless of doing that
i i now have cordano i have this great
career i've done all these amazing
things
so i think that's the the single best
way of handling power
is you have to do things to keep
yourself grounded
in case of washington he was deeply
connected mount vernon
during the revolutionary war he was like
sending letters talking about the
irrigation ditches and the bar
and things like that he was always
connected to that and also develop a
mindset that
you're only here temporarily everything
you have is finite it's going to go away
at some point no matter how much you
want to keep it you will die
and somebody else will have it so you
live for the next generation
you don't live for yourself you look to
the future you say what am i going to
leave behind what am i going to transmit
and then you in that kind of mindset
always forces you to be more
gracious cooperative and collaborative
with people all these dictators
they are egomaniacs and they they get
connected these fantasies and they live
for themselves look at she and china
he's unraveling a power structure that
was what made china china today
you know after mao they said we probably
shouldn't have another one of those guys
and so he they said let's let's build
something where there's checks and
balances
and no one person is going to run the
whole show
or else it'll descend and regress and
we'll have problems
and then what he's done he's he's
thinking only about himself not the best
interest of china
so he's systematically unraveling a
system they've been embracing for over
40 years
uh and to what end after he dies the
next guy who comes in even as he's super
confident
the next guy is going to horrifically
abuse that power structure
and the same thing happened with the
romans after augustus the great emperor
then suddenly down the line you have
caligula and nero and all these other
terrible emperors that just destroyed
everything that the republic
and the empire has sought to achieve so
i so you have to think for the future
you have to think in institutions and
systems you have to have things that
ground yourself
and you have to be fully prepared to
lose everything and give up
everything after i left ethereum i had
nothing
okay reputation was damaged not a lot of
money
nobody really want to work with me no
one pick up a phone for two whole years
it was horrible and so i was a bedrock
in that experience and now look at where
i'm at i built all the way up to that
and so that wasn't by accident it was i
had to surround myself with amazing
people
why would amazing people want to
surround themselves with me if i was
this
narcissistic who just looks like
it's me me me
everything would be a transactional
relationship
it would be okay we'll get as much as we
can and then run away as quickly as
possible
instead it was i'm going to invest in
you and maybe i'll win maybe i won't win
but you know i'll be the last guy to
leave the boat if if
we're freezing to death you get my coat
and i'll just deal with the cold that
kind of mindset
uh you have to have that i got that from
my dad he got it from his father
uh you know my grandfather and great
grandfather my dad said grew up montana
and they were like products of the
homestead act very rough
montana you know a lot of people died
and froze to death up there eaten by
animals or something or shot by their
neighbors
and nobody investigates anything because
it's montana
so the only way you survive is by taking
care of each other
and being a good member of that
community and if somebody gets big you
have this implicit desire to go and give
back and take care of the community that
you came from and invest in that
community
like i came from the mathematical
community i never completed a phd but
one of the things that i'm doing is i'm
going to put 20 million dollars and set
up a center to do automated theorem
proving and we're going to heavily
invest in lean
because i'm super excited about
mechanizing math and making machine
understandable
now i know all these guys who do this
work there's like all these
mathematicians and computer scientists
and no one pays attention to them and
they're kind of like the red-headed step
children of mathematics and they live on
the boundaries and periphery
meanwhile they're super passionate and
they absolutely love what they do
and if only they had the right resources
within 50 or 100 years what they're
doing can probably become the dominant
model
of how to do mathematics so i'm now in a
position where i have the financial
means to take care of these guys
so all i have to do is just call them up
and say hey would you like to work with
oh absolutely
and cut a check and it's done
you